yes i am here at sofi stadium where they
are getting so ready for the super bowl
i am literally standing on the field
ahead of all the fans and of course all
the hollywood celebrities who are gonna
pack this house but today e.t has an
exclusive we are going to show you the
special suites where all those a-listers
will be watching from
leo hung at the bar and rob lowe was on
the sidelines for the nfc championship
game while james corden posed with rebel
wilson and jessica alba chatted with her
parents sterling k brown takes in games
with his boys here and kate hudson has
ladies day with leslie mann all from the
comfort of their private sofa suites
these vip celeb friendly suites take up
all of level 2 of sofi and it's a
360 degree experience you'll see what i
mean let's go inside
inside the 360 experience those
exclusive ticket holders will find
everything they need for a delicious
break from the game there is premium
dining from barbecue to sushi and there
are four specialty bars wine whiskey
tequila and
champagne so grab a glass for some
champagne wishes and quarterback dreams
and now the most private space in all of
sofi we are inside the owner's club only
12 suites have access to this space so
when a famous face needs a moment away
from all the cameras this is the spot
those suites usually range from 15 to 45
thousand dollars but can go for up to
two and a half million for the super
bowl so what else do you get for that
price tag how about access to a private
nightclub this is bootsy bellows the
sister location to the famous hollywood
club and they've got everything a dj
booth a full bar we have seen many
celebrities taking in the rams games
from right here so i'm gonna live like
an a-lister
can i get a cocktail
there's no one here
[Music]